have you ever had a neighbor that was so
bad you just wished you could sue them
and get them to move out of the
neighborhood i want you out well today
we're going to indulge in your neighbor
suing fantasy with some of the worst
neighbors that have ever existed on the
matter of next door neighbors english
author gk chesterson famously quipped
the bible tells us to love our neighbors
and also to love our enemies probably
because generally they are the same
people clearly mr chesterton had some
bad neighbors himself or knows some
jaded real estate lawyers but it's an
all too relatable sentiment because few
parts of life inspire more acrimony and
generate more attorneys fees than drawn
out fights between neighbors which might
explain why neighbor disputes seem to
make up 90 of sitcom plot lines
ew
what
ugly naked guy's taking his turkey out
of the oven
and it's all too common that neighbors
are presented with straightforward
solutions to their problems but due to
pride animosity or both they choose to
dig in their heels and incur tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of dollars in legal fees instead which
is bad for neighbors but great for
lawyers so let's start with property
lines and boundary disputes perhaps the
most common neighbor dispute is when one
property owner discovers that his or her
neighbor has built a fence or other
structure that crosses the boundary line
which creates a cause of action known as
encroachment and most of the time such
encroachment is unintentional boundary
lines can date back decades or even
centuries and as time passes successor
neighbors can forget exactly where the
original lines are when a road or
structure or even a pile of rocks
extends into a neighbor's property this
also creates a cause of action for
continuing trespass and to get the court
to order the removal of these infringing
structures an individual can file a
common law action for ejectment to prove
that the individual has the sole right
to possess the property that is being
encroached or trespassed upon but
ultimately the simplest way to resolve
boundary disputes is for the parties to
get together and pay for a lot line
adjustment that moves the official
property lines to match the neighbor's
current boundaries but if every neighbor
could resolve disputes in a calm and
mature fashion there'd be no need for
this video about nightmare neighbors for
example when gabriel braun of bangor
maine discovered that his property line
included one half of his neighbor's
garage he then decided to take matters
into his own hands by sawing the garage
in half i mean from a legal perspective
absolutely the wrong way to handle that
dispute but that is some tremendously
precise construction work right there
some real matt risinger stuff we'll see
you next time on the build show
here's the background in 2012 gabriel
and his wife tracy braun moved to
gabriel's childhood home and peacefully
coexisted with their neighbor steve
ritter but things changed after mr
ritter died in 2016 and steve's widow
theresa laith ritter and their son blake
took ownership of the property gabriel
described blake as quote a terrible
neighbor who he alleged had late night
parties and was rude to the bronze and
their children the dispute escalated in
april 2020 when the bronze put down wood
chips near the previously established
boundary line to allow a tractor to
travel downhill to clean up downed tree
limbs blake responded to this act by
planting a stake in the ground where the
chips were placed and demanding that
gabriel remove the chips from what he
claimed was the ritter property gabriel
then hired two different land surveyors
to check the boundary lines who both
concluded that half of the writer's
garage was on the brawn property blake
asked gabriel for the opportunity to
remove his father's ashes from the
garage but gabriel claims his neighbor
began throwing trash and smashing glass
and throwing bureaus in front of the
lawn the next day gabriel who works in
construction sawed the garage in half
following widespread media coverage the
writers sued the bronze and the
surveyors the purported crane operator
and even media organizations that
reported on this controversy shortly
after this lawsuit was filed the judge
ordered the bronze to set aside 150 000
to pay future damages noting the ritters
would likely prevail at trial gabriel
who is representing himself and his wife
instead of hiring a lawyer now can see
that he could have handled this better
noting that he would have liked to quote
have seen a better resolution to the
dispute myself i mean sure braun could
have hired a lawyer to negotiate a
redrawing of the boundary lines kind of
like how the ritters had hired lawyers
to litigate their case but instead of
doing the sensible thing gabriel clearly
had been guided by one animating
principle how would a cartoon neighbor
act in this situation there now we live
in completely separate houses i don't
ever have to look at you
now here's some hashtag not legal advice
if you get into a legal dispute it's a
good idea to hire a lawyer instead of
trying to fix everything yourself that's
why in the legal profession we have a
saying only a fool would have himself as
a client and given the likelihood of the
self-represented bronze losing to the
lawyered up ritter clan this is just
another example of brain over braun
nailed it come for the legal analysis
and stay for the terrible puns now let's
talk about easements anyone who makes
the leap from being a renter to a
homeowner does so with the intention of
having property that is truly their own
and no one else's however what a lot of
people may not realize is that most
homes come with easements which
expressly grant certain rights to allow
third parties to enter your land and use
your property and when there are
disputes about strangers coming onto
your property that's where you can run
into problems easements grant
individuals companies or the government
the right to use or access another
individual's property for limited
purposes these easement rights typically
include physical access like the
right-of-way or utility easements that
allow public entities to install
telephone poles gas lines and other
infrastructure and parties can also
obtain negative easements which gives a
holder of the right to require a
neighbor to do or not do specific things
such as preventing an owner from
blocking the neighbor's view or
obstructing water flow and of these
easements the most common one is the
driveway easement in which a neighbor
has the right to use the property
owner's driveway to access his land you
wouldn't think that a driveway could be
a source of such conflict but then
you've never lived next to minnie driver
i mean i haven't either but judging by
her feud with her 70-something-year-old
disabled neighbor over a driveway
easement i'm not sure i want to here's
what happened in that case in september
2014 the goodwill hunting star moved in
next door to daniel perelmutter a 74
year old disabled army vet and heart
transplant survivor who walks with a
cane problems began immediately that
december when parallel mudder began
building an ultra-modern home on his
property bordering on a shared driveway
paralmutter claimed the driver had gone
to great lengths to block access to his
driveway easement that leads to several
parcels of land including driver's
property driver further blocked the
easement with the installation of an
electronic gate to protect her from the
paparazzi this was originally done with
the blessings of paralletter and his
wife but driver allegedly changed the
code and disabled the manual gate switch
after construction began in november
2015 driver obtained a temporary
restraining order against mr perelmuttar
claiming that he quote cursed us and
blew smoke in my children's faces and
otherwise put the driver family in fear
of their lives apparel mudder denies
this misconduct in 2016 the parameters
sued for trespass private nuisance
assault and intentional infliction of
emotional distress he claims in his suit
that driver threw quote baby food jars
filled with black paint against the
walls of his home driver denied pearl
mudder's allegations and claimed that he
was the one who was deliberately
blocking the driveway as perol mudder
had installed a new wall that narrowed
the driveway down from 20 to 14 feet
wide in november 2016 driver went to los
angeles superior court and perilmutter
was found guilty of contempt for
shrinking the driveway easement with his
wall he was ordered to do 10 hours of
community service and pay 200 thousand
dollars plus driver's attorney's fees to
avoid jail parallel mudder reluctantly
tore down that wall but continued to
lash out a driver in a january 2017
court hearing alleging she quote
perjured herself in every way with her
testimony of complete lies putting on a
performance worthy of an oscar winner
perilmutter then filed a new lawsuit
accusing driver of outrageous and
malicious behavior screaming insults and
obscenities at him driving at him into
her car causing twenty thousand dollars
worth of damage to his property and
threatening to have his construction
workers quote deported perilmutter also
claimed that after winning the prior
lawsuit against him he videotaped driver
gloating telling him that she was glad
he got effed and wishing that he would
lose everything as a result however it's
clear peril mudder hasn't been the most
diplomatic of neighbors either
previously telling the dailymail.com
about miss driver quote she won and i
hope she spends every dollar on
chemotherapy jesus and after three years
of fighting the neighbors finally
reached a confidential settlement
agreement for all claims in april 2018.
the presiding judge rita miller had
expressed disappointment in court that
the two couldn't resolve their
differences without litigation noting
with a chuckle the heart of the case is
who's richer than who i guess so my
legal eagles the big takeaway here is
that if you disagree with the scope of
an easement it's best to try talking
things out with your neighbor unless of
course you're very angry and have
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
legal fees in which case my telephone
line is always open but that takes us to
private and public nuisances one of the
most common complaints people have about
their neighbors is that they are
annoying and most the time being
annoying is not a crime even though it
definitely should be but at a certain
point did you know that you can be so
annoying that it actually violates the
law well this brings us to our next
legal concept nuisance law individuals
who own or occupy real estate have a
common law right to what's called quiet
enjoyment of their property meaning that
they have the right to use and enjoy
their premises in peace without
interference from the surrounding
neighbors or landlord a person commits
the tort of nuisance when a person in
possession of real property engages in
an activity that significantly
interferes with the use or enjoyment of
another's property or otherwise affects
the health safety welfare or comfort of
the public at large so when you hear
stories about nightmare celebrity
neighbors those claims typically fall
under nuisance law for example in 2011
eccentric filmmaker and foot enthusiast
quentin tarantino brought a private
nuisance lawsuit against his neighbors
true blood creator alan ball and his
partner peter mcadisi alleging their
macaw parrots emitted quote ear
splitting shrieks and screams for seven
to eight hours a day tarantino argued
that the macaws subjected him to quote
obnoxious pterodactyl-like screams which
have quote robbed mr tarantino of the
ability to find peace in his home and if
you think tarantino is exaggerating this
is what a macaque call sounds like
but sometimes the nuisance doesn't
affect one person and it affects the
public at large and there was a public
nuisance case relating to the sriracha
factory in irvine california the city of
irvine filed a public nuisance lawsuit
against the hot sauce maker after
residents began to complain about
burning eyes irritated throats and
headaches with other residents claiming
they moved outdoor activities indoors
and even would leave their homes to
avoid the stench after sriracha agreed
to install new filtration systems the
city dropped the suit in the following
year but a court is not likely to stop
every annoyance in defense of a nuisance
claim a defendant might argue that the
offending activity complies with zoning
laws and a court is less likely to halt
an activity when the local government
has approved it or defendant might also
invoke the coming to the nuisance
defense this means that if a defendant
can show that they engaged in this
conduct before the plaintiff moved to
the neighborhood the plaintiff was
therefore completely aware of the
activity and chose to live there a type
of consent so if you have a very
annoying neighbor and talking it out
doesn't work just know that you can
always call a lawyer because the one
thing you definitely shouldn't do is
start erecting things out of spite so
let's talk about spite specifically
spike fences fight houses and other
spite structures because certain
homeowners those with the time money and
malicious intent to build impractical
structures upon their land often do so
just to annoy their neighbors all for
the express purpose of taking you down
and you better believe that there is an
entire area of law devoted to such
structures now you might have heard of a
spike fence before but there's actually
all sorts of things that you can build
out of spite now the law has a specific
legal term to describe any structure
built out of spite and legal eagles i'm
going to need you to be very mature
about this because the very real legal
term is malicious erections hey hey
there is nothing funny about malicious
erections but please consult your lawyer
if you have a malicious erection lasting
more than 10 hours now perhaps the most
famous spite fence is the crocker spike
fence of san francisco where a 19th
century railroad baron built a 40-foot
fence around his neighbor's home after
they refused to sell him their house
triggering a 30-gear feud enter charles
crocker a six-foot-tall 300-pound titan
of industry who made his fortune
overseeing and financing the
construction of the central pacific
railroad crocker had but one humble
dream building a tiny twelve thousand
square foot mansion buying an entire
city block and getting san francisco to
build a residential cable car just for
the wealthy folks in the area who were
also buying entire city blocks now to
fully understand the story which took
place during the gilded age of us
history i need you to imagine a time
where wealth was concentrated in the
hands of the relatively few the owners
of these big businesses laborers toiled
for hours and hours a day never reaching
anything like what these owners of these
companies had all while these ultra rich
few felt emboldened to blow their money
on monuments to ego what's all this oh
this oh i just came from work i'm a
secret agent astronaut millionaire now
that you've pictured such a fantastical
scenario that could never possibly
happen today we must continue as this
railroad baron bought up the block and
the project neared completion in 1876
crocker the unstoppable force met an
immovable object and his name was
nicholas young young a german immigrant
who ran a mortuary was the sole holdout
who refused to sell his land so crocker
decided to torment his neighbor by
building a 40-foot fence enclosing the
neighbor's house on three sides out of
spite when robert frost wrote good
fences make good neighbors he clearly
never had a neighbor like charles
crocker after he built the spike fence
both sides then took turns trying to out
spite the other crocker ordered his
workers to arrange dynamite blast so
rock debris would pelt the young house
young threatened to block crocker's view
with a skull and crossbones flag and
place a coffin on his roof ostensibly to
advertise his business but mostly to
annoy his rich neighbor and after young
and crocker died in 1880 and 1888
respectively their heirs continued this
fight efforts to get the city to tear
down the fence went nowhere as the fence
technically broke no laws spike fences
only became illegal in california in
1913 and after withstanding a
constitutional challenge in 1920 the
modern statute was finally codified in
1953 providing that quote any fence or
other structure in the nature of events
unnecessarily exceeding 10 feet in
height maliciously erected or maintained
for the purpose of annoying the owner or
occupant of an adjoining property is a
private nuisance when young's widow died
in 1902 the rivalry dined with her their
daughter sold the land to the crocker
descendants in 1904 and the spitefence
was torn down in 1905. but all this
fighting would turn out to be pointless
as in 1906 the san francisco earthquake
and related fires burned down the entire
neighborhood apparently nature is just
as capable as man of acting out of spite
and just like spike fences are
impractical structures built
specifically to annoy spite houses are
generally built with no intention of
living there like the plum island pink
house in newbury massachusetts according
to legend a wife agreed to a divorce
from her husband on the condition that
he billed her an exact replica of their
current home but she did not specify
where the house should be built so the
husband built the home in the middle of
an isolated salt marsh that used salt
water for plumbing rendering the unit
uninhabitable and apparently spite runs
deep in the state of massachusetts
because boston also boasts its own
famous spite house as the story goes a
man returned from serving in the civil
war only to find that his brother had
built a large house on their shared land
and since the civil war adequately
prepared him for brothers being on
opposite sides the spurned sibling built
a 10.4 foot wide skinny house to block
all sunlight and view of his brother's
home now in 2017 the property was sold
to private owners for nine hundred
thousand dollars but spike structures
are not just a thing in the distant past
back in 2017 gave her nichols an
architect neighbor in alexandria
virginia decided to build a new garage
two feet from neighbors paul and patrice
lynan's property to block their first
floor window the linens missed their
15-day period to object to the garage
because nichols began construction while
they were out of town and the city later
concluded that the spike garage was not
technically illegal a year later the
alexandria city council amended the code
to now require all structures to be at
least five feet away from a home with a
basement or first floor window within
three feet of the shared property line
but there are so many ways that you can
spite your neighbors as illustrated by
one michigan man and vermont man who
individually decided to construct the
ultimate symbol of spite a giant middle
finger in michigan strip club
entrepreneur alan markovitz purchased
the home next to his ex-wife then built
a 12-foot high spotlit bronze middle
finger sculpture in his backyard
markovic claims his wife had an affair
with someone he knew and felt compelled
to spend seven thousand dollars for the
chance to flip them off every day
markovitz is no stranger to making
enemies having been famously shot twice
once in the face had a mob contract
taken out on his life and had an
ex-girlfriend drive a pontiac fiero
through one of his clubs and similarly
in westford vermont business owner ted
pelkey had reached the boiling point
after fighting an 11-year battle against
the town's development review board
which had repeatedly denied his building
permit application for an 8 000 square
foot garage mr pelkey had previously
expressed his displeasure in
less than legal ways like in 2011 when
he allegedly threatened to shoot a town
official if he stepped on his property
some people in my situation would have
probably went and bought a gun but
instead i said well
i'd rather just put up a big middle
finger in the front yard
and just tell them what i think of them
years later mr pelkey found a not quite
unique but slightly less threatening way
to express his displeasure with the town
officials he spent four thousand dollars
on a 700 pound chainsaw carved wooden
middle finger perched atop a 16 foot
pole although one might think that this
would qualify as a spike structure or
even a public nuisance as it flips off
the whole town the government apparently
could not do anything about it that's
because the middle finger does not
advertise a product or service so it
does not fall under vermont's billboard
law instead it likely qualifies as
public artwork protected under the first
amendment the town has fought for pelky
to take it down but the middle finger
remains and it inspired a short film a
very large gesture now if your neighbor
sets up a giant fence that you can't get
around you won't be able to shop for
groceries but you can spite them by
having your meals delivered from
hellofresh now i'm a do-it-yourself
person and i have to say i was initially
pretty skeptical about hellofresh i'm a
pretty good cook so i didn't think that
i needed any help but i actually loved
it even for an experienced cook
hellofresh delivers new ingredients and
recipes that i'd never try on my own and
as the weather gets cold you'll
experience comforting home-cooked meals
like chicken ramen with shoyu broth and
turkey ragu gnocchi and i don't know
about you but i would never attempt
those on my own and everything i've
gotten from hello fresh is insanely
delicious easy to cook and really
healthy so if you feel like you've been
cooking the same thing over and over
again at home hellofresh is a great
solution and there are 50 menu and
market items to choose from every week
including vegetarian calorie smart and
gourmet options so you have plenty of
variety and it's not just meals their
marketplace gives you a ton of add-ons
for breakfast desserts and seasonal
snacks like pillsbury pumpkin cookie
dough and it saves time too i usually
increase the size of my hellofresh
serving so i can enjoy the leftovers for
lunch and of course everything was
delivered straight to my door so i
didn't even have to do any shopping the
produce actually gets to you faster than
a grocery store so it arrives at peak
freshness and flavor and it cuts out
meal planning so the recipes only take
20 to 30 minutes literally less time to
cook than it would normally take to do
the shopping itself and plus it's
incredibly sustainable since the
ingredients are pre-portioned there's
less prep less wasted food and the
packaging is almost entirely made from
recyclable or recycled content
hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower than that of meals
made from store-bought groceries so if
you would like to try hellofresh and
you've got to try these meals you can go
to hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle14 for up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts yes you can actually
get 14 free meals and that includes free
shipping or you can just click on the
link below so again for up to 14 free
meals and three gifts go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle14 or just click on the link
that's on screen right now or in the
description plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel and while
you're at it click on this playlist over
here with all my other legal stories so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court